and jutsu investigations which are
ongoing just let their protection keep
all new the interpretation which for us
particle pollution aerial cheeky
combination fact Kaku can si music El
Monte Paranal Duran wha da six an
American spy from the Shanta memory
which is leading the investigation and
from us as well let that sort of propose
even the intent of the most probable
interpretation is that the copilot
bearing up still sure Ronald a cheater a
voluntary abstention Mulder
a voluntary resume and say missus used
to open the cabin door of
will come on ball to their pilot doodle
real a book directly he refused to open
the cockpit door here actually and all
action and all a better than fasten
which indicate starts the descent
procedure to Juba repeal coup and I
remind you down your mute that in the
last eight minutes they Sarah plane lose
when with the firm about you
twelve thousand meters through the glove
- mm you don't hate Texas or the Rio
summit until it hit the mountain which
is between 1500 2000 meters
any action that's personal q Jordan
using your visible for a reason which we
still don't know why
personal use a glad they did three a set
of you wish we can only deduct that it
destroyed this plane really morally done
easily